Bob Woodward associate editor of The
Washington Post now joins us he and Carl
Bernstein led the papers coverage of the
Watergate scandal that ended with
President Richard Nixon's resignation
that's Woodward on the right in this
photo Bob good morning when you were
take this when you look at this
last-minute negotiation over the tax
bill does it look familiar to the
legislation you've seen before the
last-minute negotiations well this is
exactly the way not to do tax reform I
remember in the 70s when I started
reporting lawyers said the tax code was
about that big on the Shelf it's now
this big you can't go add it in in in
this way and it would make so much sense
now for everyone to just say let's wait
till after Christmas let's let people
see what this is it's an important issue
it affects everyone but you know we're
in the era of impatience and speed and
political promises so it looks like
something might have but and we'll see
well you know talk about waiting till
after Christmas Bob the Democrats are
saying they want to delay the vote until
after senator doug jones senator like
doug jones is seated in january do you
see any chance of that happening that's
unlikely there's a momentum to this
president Trump has made it very clear
he doesn't want to end the year without
some success some accomplishment but
let's say you know this is if you go
back to the beginning of the Obama
presidency when they rammed through
Obamacare and really have been paying
for it since because I remember talking
last year with Trump about this when he
was a candidate that all successful
politics is coalition building you've
got to include some of the other side
and Trump said oh absolutely I know that
but we're not seeing that practiced by
both sides too bad Bob let me move on to
the russia investigation especially
following up on that stunning Washington
Post report about Trump's advisors
having to tiptoe around the Russia issue
anytime it comes up there are some who
think that he's trying to discredit Bob
Muller and some around him are trying to
discredit Bob Muller in hopes of one day
firing him what's the likelihood that
you think that'll happen
well you know the the future is veiled
on this obviously there's tension but if
if Trump is correct he thinks there's no
collusion and nothing here he should
welcome a full investigation that post
story showed that he just does not agree
with the overwhelming conclusion of the
intelligence community so again this is
something we're going to have to wait
and see about but you know that is not
the emotional culture we're living in
wait and see it's let's do it let's have
a fight let's have a political skirmish
you have covered a lot of national
security systems within different
administrations you know about the
coordination that's required the dance
steps that have to be careful to make
good policy so with that context in that
knowledge assess that reporting about
what is done in the national security
apparatus around the president with
respect to Russia and what that means
for just making good decisions well that
you know that's a kind of a side issue I
I'm doing a book on Trump for next year
and trying to look at the big picture
and some of the components and the good
news is in the first year of the Trump
administration we have not had a major
escalation of a war or a new war and as
you get into the weeds on this where I
have I have some time to do that there
is a rather long and serious debate on
lots of these issues like the Middle
East how to deal with China North Korea
so it's not all bad news but this
tension on Russia needs to be settled
alright Bob Woodward thanks